j'en suis aujourd'hui on se trouve pour
l'avant-dernier épisode until then we
say pas dernier mais le dernier et
upload en même temps que celui ci qui
est l'avant dernier donc c'est tout
bénef aller le précédemment dans le till
dawn htc c'est pas mal je suis désolé à
chlef et pour le vieux alors aucune
trace grands
qu'est ce que tu cherches une autre
sortie mike ya pas de clé pour le
téléphérique josh il doit la voir et me
c'est quoi tout ça elle a probablement
emmenées dans la mine verte
vous savez quoi faire
compris c'est dangereux d'or je vais
vite revenir et c'est là que mike pas
tout seul chapitre 9 karma deux heures
jusqu'à l'aube
alors il veut aller chercher la clé du
téléphérique pour qu'ils redescendraient
cette [ __ ] de montagne mais
apparemment c'est josh qu'il avait voilà
d'occident le boudin jones qui s'est
fait kidnapper par des windigo à l'ego
on y va aller wendy aulas l'amusement
l'amusement on commence plus tard au
moment où je suis tout excité visage et
3 2 alors la suite de l'histoire
là je ne vois pas comment ça ça peut
être l'avant dernier épisode est pas le
dernier à avoir des péripéties de
malades à mon avis ça va être ultra
lourd
en plus il a pas tarder il y va il n'a
pas d'armes où sont passés les loups a
c'est vrai mais des loups [ __ ] on peut
jouer je m'étais fait poteau avec l'un
mon gars en effet dû pierre weiss et on
s'est amusé de pouf on a fait du
borderlands en co-op et toute la
cheville en moi easy windigo qui nous
coupent la tête
alors qu'est-ce qu'il ya ici pourquoi je
suis allé là en armes au oui avec tout
plein de balles de fusil j'ai même pas
vu alors là mon gain dé refait allez on
allume ça tout de suite oui oh oui bonne
grosse poignée de balle mais qui prend
là qu'est ce tu prends la caisse même
sur ta tête tu m'as je franchirai pas
allez on reprend des balles reprenait
mal [ __ ] damidot n'a pas pris assez
fermé tu tires bras comme ça tient
vraiment absolument tout le monde
voilà michael lin bagdad à copenhague au
ne l'attaquent pas mike respecte avec
lui répète avec lui voila voila vous et
souvenez à ce moment là j'avais le choix
de le frapper aux pages n'avait pas
frappé
j'avoue j'ai un lutin pièce vient de
retrouver
yes allez je te demande sur lui tout est
maman tu as manqué nouvelles sont donc
j'ai vraiment à l'eau [ __ ] mais j'ai
tellement bien fait pas le frapper le
moment où la vue je suis hyper content
dollars frappé voilà vivent les animaux
vivent les scherwiller chair vive les
loups n'ont entry danger de mort allez
on y va à mon cas on a du feu on a un
look à part google arrive à les attirer
le conte [ __ ] j'aime pas très parlant
de moi revient là faut lui donner un os
[ __ ] de deux loups voilà festives
halles et se marrent fait emmerdes s'y
faufiler moi je suis faible aux anneaux
regardez il ya une manivelle et moi vont
s'appuyer sur la manivelle et huawei
annonce à m'enfermer annoncé bon ça ou
la deuxième bon tout ça ça fait penser à
juste une légende quand son chien part
dans un endroit sombre et oui qui le
perd de vue c'est horrible mon petit
stick d'abord et moi brunstein l'âge
tourner la torche de feu aux ja 20 wang
zhiguo à droite mon gars faut le brûler
tim attention pas trop vite
reste à côte avant à protège mon band
aid newcits bon ok c'est mon truc à moi
je suis bien
arrête à brailler [ __ ] il se repère au
son espèce d'imbécile de l'oua on y va
le loup c'est parti à la rencontre tu me
laisses bien passé devant troyes et
sarah c'est bon et négoce non non ça
c'est rien je vais pas tirer ça c'est
rien c'est pas windigo saharien frère
c'est un vieux rat nul ça s'apprend
e'lara [ __ ] faut pas le jour à toi et
tous détestés pour la mort de christian
vous allez vous détestez suis désolé je
veux pas je veux pas tu veux pas et ça
se trouve
au fait on m'a dit que ça se trouve
c'est anna en fait on avait la tête de
bêtes mais pas celle d'allah bongain au
nom d'un [ __ ] on fait quoi on fait
quoi
allez à gauche droite avant droit devant
mon gars droit devant
comme ça gagnent fort tu la fermes voilà
exactement tac tac au grand bornand
fermer l'eau mais au nom s'est pas loupé
hutin ça sert à rien ça réussit blot
n'engage pas une balle non non non non
voilà pauvre mr bah allez ciao ciao ça
j'aime bien espacé ouvrir là le windigo
un peu malade quoi elles m'ont gaza
s'est couché lui va bien au non ferme la
porte mais qu à l'eso que je te tire
dessus
voilà ses hôtes vas-y je tiens à bien
viser cette fois encore [ __ ] ils sont
répugnants men on arrête ça moi c'est
chaud de ces méga show là le futur os
donc pas là la gauche mec je me suis
trompé
ah non je suis deg attention aux
chaussées chose c'est chaud c'est chaud
là je suis toujours du la voilà steve
steve héros avec nos études on cherche
ce que tu fais pas de bruit
si tu fais du boulot honnêtement avec
[ __ ] on en maître sur vidéo aucun
bruit
car oui
hockey steve tu fais pas de bruit
ce taux plein
[Musique]
je vais arrêter dax picard et bros
[Applaudissements]
c'est le taux le plus de l'histoire
vidéo c'est pas dur et hagen
l'abattoir stupide a coûté de parler
sans quoi c'est rare et en plus tu les
as tes bras c'est sûr il est enfermé il
a enfermé il a enfermé notamment à rien
de tirer quand il aidé à une dame
j'étais en train de me gratter mais faut
pas gratter
je me gratte cul c'est mort aulas j'ai
vu le cutter et ouais haut du parcours
routier au c'est ça ça il est retenu il
est retenu ce trop tard mon gars ça me
dont vous allez être tondu vous n'aurez
pas votre cas ricco home gastines
extrémistes non ça s'arrêterait il y en
a bien un qui m liberté allez simmons
casse s'il fait quoi six buts à rien à
lui pas par exemple il faut tirer à lui
mon gars tu te retirer rien n'est pas
voter car le monde chez le poisson gym
sacré wii est plus petit incident s'il
vous plaît c'est bon ça on va mettre à
niveau diront là-dedans aux questions de
jean poiret vas-y tire de leur métier
pape et l'a ralenti ego bombay
son maman feu vous avez fait ça [ __ ]
on aurait dit un peu folle et nouveau
avec un jeu trop aller sa ferme ta j'ai
cru que j'avais carbonisé mike giffin
dans le truc
karzaï culpabiliser et steve steve hill
et où ces palabres de steve qu'on a vu
en fera sur l'âge que j'ai pas tué mon
sallabi d'enjeux haye avant windigo de
l'autre côté je les ai vus en on est
dans doute oui steve gohouri steve
bordel [ __ ] moi j'aime bien que ya
steve quand même ce qu'il ainsi même
source que moi j'ai pas un serpent de
son petit chat room non ouais ouais
la hausse était jolie comme lens habitat
s'avance en dansant vas tu ferme la
porte
fuir le mariage mariage michael
target tellement je veux pas tuer mike
ce nom mais je veux pas tuer mike alessi
allait bien mais steve jobs steve onze
mois plus tard alors mystifie palais
bien avec moi si ça autour d'un thé les
ballons bien qu'on s'attend pas à voir
des gars ont fait on fait une fuite à la
nage à la amy n'est mon gars on n'a pas
le temps alors qu'on a chuté au plus
voilà c'était ça la bonne idée [ __ ] on
a vu qu'ils soient pas mike tu en as
honte à toi tu es una tout brûler ya
plus de when i go sur l'île oh [ __ ]
j'suis content vous me pardonnez du
combattant pour qui j'ai appris de mes
erreurs regarder la petite âme
non non il est mort il est mort ou
plutôt c'était chaud en cette jeunesse
[Musique]
non elle est vivante
non elle est vivante non elle a survécu
à la chute de l'ascenseur mais elle sait
pas que c'est de wendy goiti pas de
problème voilà au hockey on pas sur ça
mais milliers h à ta journée encore cinq
paires sommet de copenhague s'est passé
deux astronautes partis
ok thomson grande porte ah oui oui qui a
dû fermer derrière mais il a bien fait
il a bien fait trois mois la regarde la
plaque tac bima bond passant par les
égouts ça c'est quoi l'ambassadeur il
allait acheter 20 ans emilie team à
emilie je t'aime pas c'est ça qui me
brière non pas c'est ok on est seul on
joue à son école dans le tunnel le plus
glauque d'europe 1 mais c'est quoi là
bas vous aux thématiques
oh non
non non tu es toi tais toi tais toi qui
es là
y'a quelqu'un jusqu'à nantua jusqu'à
avec une bonne rhinopharyngite sa
rejoindre le groupe rejoint le groupe
enquêter sur la voie méfaits soient mes
fesses sam
j'arrivais vous oh yes ou juste là ouais
quoi
l'échelle est foutu on n'arrivera jamais
là oh non non non je crois que je peux
j'ai mes chances
c'est comme un mur d'escaladé en
occultant of the beast dans trois de
l'un cherche et mike bonne chance mais
c'est pareil [ __ ]
arrêtez de me séparer s'il vous plaît
aux oyats josh qui est tombé là qui part
est-ce qu'ils ont tué ou pas ça se
trouve c'est anna k récupérer josh et du
coup elle n'a pas tué non je pense
d'ailleurs bizarre a peut-être ok on
arriver en haut du mur [ __ ] c'est
fantastique
une branlée ah oui fait la maligne ou
josh est ton meilleur où on peut aller
là on peut aller tout droit
or il ya trois chemins mais qu on peut
monter ou pas par là ouais on peut assez
mal qu'au dessus casas et peut-être
quand mike attire dans les tonneaux au
dessus en fait ça fait ça non non non je
t'en supplie je t'en supplie non josh
josh josh wink pitié
au pelage est méritée mais je m'en bats
les os
[ __ ] aux mecs mais il est enfin
qu'est-ce qui fait là sans déconner
[ __ ] mick fanning est rien mike c'est
un guerrier mon gars je vous l'êtes
avertira propres à des boîtes mails à
oui c'est enfin [ __ ] oh oh eh ben on
se retrouve pour le dernier épisode en
quelques secondes et j'ai envie de
savoir la fois plus que valable
et ben voilà l'épisode sera violée en
même temps que celui ci normalement ou
peut-être deux ans après jean serrières
a tout de suite au revoir vous l'avez vu
vous l'avez vu non non pas mal non